we have no quarrel just thought I could
use the exercise I'll take that as a
threat begin
finally a giant monster to fight beside
the name is Hellboy begin look at you
Fame and bulging you are very funny glad
you appreciate my quit begin
how did you get loose got shanghaied
here by Brainiac should I be concerned
begin you expect the best of God
wouldn't be the first time me an admires
your cottage begin what do you bring to
that's fine exact good looks quick wit
and a killer right hook wait'll you see
my begin that helmets ridiculous you
take my optic blast seriously oh we're
cooking with gas
begin Wow
meeting you is just so cool easy kid
mister guy doing his job mind if we get
a picture after begin
nice ray gun you got there this gun can
stop the flash against me crap begin
lady I really don't want to do this
aren't you the least bit curious don't
say I didn't warn you
begin can't decide if you're scary
you wrote joke once I have your tongue
I'm gonna push the needle towards scary
begin
the regime won't take no for an answer
how about screw you that was your last
chance begin I've a scheme world but I
never cheat and you're telling me this
why so you know that your death comes
fairly begin your people aren't you just
means there's more amitabh of respector
begin tired of people trying to control
your fate is preordained like hell it is
begin those flames look pretty hard a
freaking kit bird what do you think ow
begin pal said you were big red and ugly
right back at you up I guess I deserve
that
begin
your mind games that worth crap it's dog
food I ain't foolin with you funky begin
well speak of the devil
always this funny it's an off day for me
begin
while you wear that ring to protect
everything in this sector and how's that
working out for you begin makes sense if
you know the story begin
can the BPRD handle two of us let's just
say the professor is concerned
what could possibly go wrong
begin weave more in common than you care
to admit you're crazy I'm saying
end of story that's what the others
thought to begin
[Music]
my plants would like a word with you
your plants can go to hell
then let's get rough begin your deals
what exactly I'm cure for a sick sad
world
if I had a nickel for every time I've
heard that
begin you cosplaying or what you don't
want any part of this friend prepare to
be amazed
begin Trigon destroyed the world once
and now are we both standing here the
Teen Titans saved it naturally begin
your colds not gonna slow me down do you
think so
demonstrates your ignorance that's a
hell of a thing to say begin
hard to tell but you look grumpy
aren't you perceptive
I'm Way more of a Sun and fun girl begin
goddamn shame what a good guy who are
you to judge me a guy who knows a thing
or two about evil begin you should meet
my friend Liz
Judith funk you'd love her she's a real
fire start begin you've got spirit in
spades the Beast like you doesn't scare
here I'd thought we'd be friends begin